now well it's the talk that not a lot of
people want to have and that's
pre-planning your funeral Advocates at
Gideon's Memorial Chapel are trying
though to try to break the stigma
surrounding death within the
African-American Community Mary Jane
beliesza shares the push for why this
conversation is so important
talking about death may be a taboo
subject for many but those at giddens
Memorial Chapel say it doesn't have to
be they're raising Awareness on end of
life planning through education and
empowerment come plan early put in
writing what you want we have a lot of
family members that they don't know if
their loved one wanted to be buried or
cremated Dr Raymond giddens Jr is the
CEO and funeral director of giddens
Memorial Chapel we as African-Americans
we celebrate death you know when it
comes to the actual rituals of death but
the taboo of actually talking about it
is alarming he says end of life planning
isn't widely common among African
Americans leading to financial burden
and conflict we've seen the X soon to be
ex-wife take over when the mom thought
she was in charge or the children
thought they were in charge so it
alleviates a lot of extra stress that
some of the families are going through
where we actually plan ahead most of the
times we hear this I wasn't ready or I
don't know what to do Ashley Jackson is
the CEO of funeral Advocates of Amer
focusing on community outreach well no
one's ready even if you have planned no
one's ready for
that
feeling of grief and loss when you lose
a loved one but it absolutely helps when
some Affairs are in order Jackson says
while we may not know when or how we'll
pass end of life planning allows you to
take control everyone has to agree so
bodies are held up oftentimes because
everyone's on the same page that's why
Dr giddens Jr plans a community event
every February during black history
month so families can take charge and be
prepared we're bringing families
together to celebrate Black History
educate them on the how death care has
been a part of black history who was the
first black embalmer allowing families
to come and taste a variety of different
foods but also at the same time we want
to pause and just remind people to get
your Affairs and orders we're going to
have resources